well joining us now is transport
secretary grant chaps it all falls on
him um why are we so underprepared
well we've never seen temperatures like
this like literally ever this probably
the big the hottest day in history um
and a lot of our infrastructure is just
not built for these types of
temperatures so
on the railways for example and i i've
tested this and queried it very hard
but it's not just the 40 degree
temperatures we might hit outside on the
ground those rails couldn't be heating
up to 50 60 and hotter
and that means they're in serious danger
of buckling so you end up having to run
the trains slower over them and that of
course causes disruption as well but
gradually we're having to upgrade all
the infrastructure including the
overhead lines which are gradually being
replaced with
the types which won't sag even in
extreme temperatures but that's a whole
new thing the country needs to get used
to bob ward who's head of policy and
communications at the london school of
economics says
there's no excuse he said we've been
reporting on um this heat wave um and we
knew it was coming um and we should have
done more about it yeah i mean we
certainly knew it's coming for the last
few days obviously we've been seeing it
in the papers this is infrastructure
warming yeah i was going to say this
infrastructure the things which take
decades to build and replace
three years ago when i became transport
secretary quite literally one of the
first conversations i had with the chief
executive of network rail andrew haynes
was about these uh overhead lines on the
railways which tend to sag in heat
and he talked me through the new
upgraded specifications which are going
into
onto the railway lines where they can
withstand much higher levels of
temperature and we're going to see this
a lot more regularly we we know that
we've seen many of the hottest days ever
recorded have come
in the last 10 to 15 years so we're
going to see this more it's a huge
infrastructure to replace and how long
is it going to take
decades actually to replace it all so
we're going to have this sort of problem
to come we are um and you know ditto
with things like uh tarmac on the roads
and obviously there are thousands if
that millions of miles of of roads in
total um so there's a long process of
replacing and upgrading it um to
withstand temperatures either very hot
or sometimes actually much colder than
we'd be used to and these are the
impacts of global warming is there a
cobra meeting today uh no there's a
cabinet this morning uh instead i think
um i'm not aware whether there's a
specific cobra meeting uh today should
be the end of the experience of the year
there is no hottest day ever yeah but
the big cobra meetings throughout
including official ones do not go well
the prime minister chairs cabinet which
is the sort of the ultimate body is at
work cobra sits under um that a lot of
times people misunderstand how cobra
this which stands for committee uh a
cabinet office briefing room uh is the
name of cobra it is literally that it's
a cabinet office briefing cabinet sits
on top of that so it's more important if
you like and i know the pm has been
keeping in touch with it he was on the
phone to me over the weekend uh about
and we spoke about several aspects he
just dials it in then well uh yeah cobra
is actually chaired officially by
somebody called the chancellor of the
duchy of lancaster which is a cabinet
colleague uh called kit mount malt house
yeah we had him on yesterday and kit's
job is to look after the civil
contingencies secretariat sometimes um
chair cobra then yeah it depends what
the issue is so for example when uh
ukraine literally when the country is
melting is that not a big enough issue
well it's not that's not a big enough
issue but cabinet is a bigger uh if you
like a bigger platform uh for a prime
is a subject minister than
last tuesday uh sure yes but as you say
we know it's been coming for a long time
so he's complacent about it i i look i
just don't i know where you're going
with this i just i'm saying that the
prime minister should be in charge the
cap prime minister is in charge and i
look i just don't agree and it's a
mischaracterization of the way that
these things operate people think
because it has cabin offers briefing
room ahead of it it somehow is more
important than for example cabinet where
we held a cabinet last week there's a
cabinet this morning
who's in touch with all his ministers
about it and the as i was mentioning the
chancellor let me just complete this
point there is something called
hold on one second there's something
called the uh civil contingency
sectariat so that's the organization
within the cabinet office that looks
after civil emergencies this kind of
overheating for example there is a
minister in the cabinet well i think
it's absolutely as emergency okay
there isn't a cabinet minister call the
chancellor the duchy of lancaster is an
old-fashioned name for it whose job it
literally is to to do this stuff and
look after it and he's been um doing
that very admirably as you say you had
him on yesterday morning yeah and you
don't feel that the prime minister
should be leading from the front when
it's a civil emergency so so he has been
he's been being brutal hasn't he
partying at flipping checkers
again you know i know you love this
media narrative on it it's just like
that's it bash the media that's what we
should do no no no it's just it's just a
sort of it's just he needs to be seen to
be leading from the front and he's not
because he's checked out
it's literally not true in fact in fact
exactly the opposite is is is the truth
one second uh one second is literally
the opposite is the truth uh in fact
he's been interested in and involved in
the detail of for example uh ensuring
what's he doing this for because because
in the end he has responsibility for
britain he's leaving in six weeks so he
still has response why didn't he do it
two years ago
i'm sure he's been up in uh raf aircraft
before
he's leading britain's security at a
time of war and you're telling me the
prime minister he's leaving in six weeks
he does not need to do a maverick style
uh photo shoot like that
look that's that's that's your view i
don't i don't think it's only my view i
don't agree with you because in the end
the prime minister is in charge of this
country's security there is a war going
on in europe why on earth would he not
go and meet with the ref because we've
got a civil emergency with the heat
rising higher than it's ever been before
it's quite possible to do two things at
once okay obviously not uh reports that
rishi uh sunak spoke to liz trust after
this uh channel four debate on friday
and said uh why why are we doing this
this isn't working what was he talking
about i'm not privy to the specific
conversation but i do think that um
there's already been two
um debates public debates as well as
many different hustings for the actual
electorate at this point which are the
conservative mps uh and i think they
took the decision collectively as
candidates to say actually they wanted
to focus on this stage which is in the
house i'm sure when it goes out to the
last two there'll be opportunity for
more debates and no doubt rishi and
others will join that debate well we
haven't heard their views on things like
housing when they've gone up against
each other or health
or even really what's going to happen as
tomorrow's strike action is concerned so
let me put it to you given that you're
representing rishi sunak this morning
what's he going to do um about sorting
out the housing crisis
i'm sure he'll have very comprehensive
plans for housing uh he'll be outlining
them in the later stages
evening couldn't he i know i know that
you would love to have had them on your
program of course i think my viewers
should have the opportunity and i know
some of your viewers may have caught
them both on itv and channel 4
previously
who would be the next prime minister
naught point three percent of the
electorate will decide who the next
prime minister is my viewers surely have
um unless the tory members have a right
to put questions to whoever whoever
would want to be the next prime minister
of course and there's still they've been
told they can't hold on second they're
still like what is it seven weeks to go
until the prime minister's um selected
there's plenty of opportunity to do that
that's right from the the finances
well this way you get
at this stage um it's only mps as you've
mentioned who get to narrow it down
whittle it down to the final two when
it's in the final two anyone who's a
party member everyone's welcome to join
at conservatives.com
can sign up um although actually i
should mention just for you guys you
can't vote if you join right now but
normally you could you can join there's
more members now than when for example i
was uh party chairman under david
cameron so membership's gone up not
point three percent of the electorate
not the population of course what about
health how would you tackle the crisis
in the nhs uh just that was another
topic that was discovered well let me
just ask you that one because it was
another question that was put by one of
our viewers who can no longer ask the
would-be prime minister how will you
tackle this was the question how will
you tackle the crisis in the nhs a lack
of access to gps especially face-to-face
hospital weights ambulance weights and
how will you fund your plan yeah i mean
and these are all questions that um that
your viewers will be able to put i'm
sure to the final two because i'm sure
that rishi and whoever the other
candidate is if it is those two uh will
be able to uh will be happy to submit
themselves to debate so it's not that
people won't get the opportunity to
clarify then is rishi tsunak saying that
he will do a head-to-head debate with
liz trust or penny mordant on sky well
first four
i was gonna say first of all to take
nothing for granted rishi has to get
through to the final i've no doubt at
all uh that there'll be further public
tv debates and at that point at that
point i'm sure he'd be happy to do it so
will he appear on sky news as a head to
head i can't commit rishi's time to sky
news specifically but i am so saying
that there will be an opportunity for my
uh viewers to put questions to your
candidates now unclear whether this
conversation's about whether he
specifically comes on and the candidates
come on sky news or just so that might
be so that mark no because they have
done two tv debates and as i said might
surely are you saying that the sky news
heroes who are watching this morning are
less valued no i'm simply saying i'm
simply saying they've already done i've
realized he hasn't come and the other
candidates haven't come on your program
but it is the case so i'm sure they'll
be delighted
to go on tv
um will they be get an opportunity to
i'm sure yeah on sky news i don't know
if it will be on sky you and the other
broadcasters and the candidates
yeah um so let's go back to that health
question then um given that they might
not be able to ask the question the lady
that uh posed the question works in the
health service and she'd like to um
tackle the crisis in the nhs she wants
to know how you're going to do it lack
of access to gps especially face-to-face
hospital weights ambulance weights and
how will you fund your plan well first
of all we put in record funding in fact
rishi was responsible as chancellor for
doing that
due to coronavirus we've had these huge
backlogs
starting to get on top of them i was
looking last night at the figures for
example for uh weights for operations at
the upper end and those have been
starting to come down it's really
important that uh you know we make sure
that the gps are able to uh well people
are able to access their gps which is
something of great concern
and i think things like well i think i
was gonna say i think things like some
of the new technology which has been
used during coronavirus can really help
so before coronavirus a very small
percentage of um of patients had the nhs
app now people have downloaded that a
lot more they're able to access and book
appointments 14 million people waiting
for an appointment probably by the end
but by the end of this session um by the
time of the next election of it is by
2024 is that not a priority well so
a massive priority uh right now the
waiting lists are not at the 14 million
that's a prediction that's one of the
reasons why um rishi as chancellor has
brought in the health and social care
levy now that was controversial of
course as you know because it involved
uh right raising national insurance in
order to pay for uh reducing amongst
other things reducing the waiting list
so when you when your listener asks
what's going to happen action has been
taken in order to raise the money in
order to reduce the lists which have
grown because of corona viruses we all
know so uh i think regional questions
we're out of time so frustrating nice to
see i see as well much appreciated